[Music]
can light improve people's performance
at work that question is being
investigated by scientists at the
Technical University in Cologne
the doctor and engineer who make up the
research team are fascinated by the
possibilities offered by light emitting
diodes they can tune and concentrate the
light from LEDs and easily control color
and brightness ideal conditions for
researching the effects of light on
concentration and creativity could light
be the key to more effective work
practices Ashdown least averse he sure
does the astonishing thing for us was
that we noticed an effect on behavior
and cognition that was dependent on
color temperature and that was
unexpected and if elation get out you
would maybe expect a difference between
sunlight and artificial light but color
temperature also played a role physician
Evelyn
that discovery was made here in a
standardized test 50 students had to
answer questions the time allowed and
the questions asked were always the same
only the lighting was different
what's called color temperature a
characteristic of visible light was
carefully altered over the course of the
experiment
the team also tracked medical factors
such as pulse rate
the results shows that the subjects
achieved different results when the
research has changed the color
temperature of the LEDs Yama's viscacha
despair mom vie smelly warm white light
boosted creativity one does as OD of
Maxim kite logical tasks on the other
hand were better solved in cold white
light could so cold white light is
better if you're taking an exam and if
you want to be creative turn on a warm
white light source most ya da musica oh
yeah I know Bamba is a least trilha
Harbin students at the University don't
spend all their time on the theoretical
side of research they also have to
develop prototypes of new electronic
devices themselves with a bit of help
from a local company
some of them built a light control unit
then they developed an app to control
the color of the light at a workstation
or in the living room so according to
the user's task or preference the light
can be changed seamlessly from bright
white to bluish reddish or greenish
tones in future the engineers plan to
design an even more refined control
system they want to mix artificial light
with the prevailing daylight to provide
constant ideal conditions
you
[Music]